how's it going guys today in design
patterns I think we're up to episode 12.
we're going to look at the visitor
example and how a visitor works this is
a behavioral pattern and it essentially
lets you decouple some functionality
from your uh whatever your components
may be so uh to get started here and
make a little example I've opened up our
project as you can see here and I made a
new folder and done the usual with our
cmake and we do every episode I've got a
main here ready to go and for the code
that's going to be above this main as
how to design a general visitor I'm
going to include visitor so we're going
to head on over to that header forever
once and we're going to start the
example so first we need to declare some
interfaces and some classes we're going
to need some things to operate on the
visitor is going to need to know about
those so let's just say you know these
could be anything these could be
whatever you use within your game I'm
just going to call it component a and
we'll make a fuse apples will go
component B component C so these are
whatever you're instantiating in your
class that you want to visit and that
might make more sense later all right so
we need an interface for the visitor and
it should look something this so I'll go
ahead and get it typed up here
and we need some visit operations in
this class uh we'll have like visit
component these functions would probably
be called more aligned to what they do
but you essentially need to call some
have some functions that these are going
to call later which will make more sense
later
and uh we'll just do it like that these
are all going to be const because uh
they're not going to change anything
they're only going to visit things and
run function stuff like that they only
can do public stuff all right so let's
go ahead and
well we want to pass in the element
we're going to operate on here so we're
gonna go cause uh component a and what
do we can call this element or whatever
we want to call it comp
so we have a visit component a takes
component a okay kind of weird right I
don't know let's make a couple more of
these though it'll make more sense here
shortly uh see there all right so this
is this is the main interface then
obviously it's pure virtual you can't
instantiate it so where do we go from
here all right well we'll get back to
that but it's these things have to be in
a certain order because just the way the
header order is and knowing about things
it only knows about things above it
so let's go ahead and declare our base
component class so this base component
class uh we want to also make an
interface but this one is basically
going to have now let's make a
Destructor here and uh there we go
that's just wired
might actually want one of those on the
visitor too but we're going to skip it
and then we also want to have an accept
so this is going to accept a visitor and
we want to do it as a pointer naturally
it has to be a pointer because this is a
virtual pure virtual class so it can
accept a real instantiation of that has
to be like that and that's all we need
for the component so we got a couple
interfaces here in that order so now
what we want to do is just Define what
these actual components are so we can
just go class component a and that's
going to be public component
and we're going to have a public method
and we're going to make this accept
method here uh work so we at least got
to have that so we just go virtual void
accept visitor star visitor same thing
const and then over right and what's
going on here with the formatting there
we go much better and basically we want
to have this one call what you would
expect visit component a
so there we go now you can see how that
would work if you instantiate component
a if you pass it some kind of visitor it
will call this visit component a
function which they must substantiate
but uh the important thing here well
interesting thing here is all right so
these any of these public functions the
visitor can do stuff with so you want to
have some public functions here to do
stuff let's just uh I don't know we'll
return some strings say maybe you know
maybe you have a git name or get
something about it and return to
strength that could be that could be
fine so we just want to go like
component a function I guess sure we
don't necessarily want these all to be
the same name it's that would get
confusing but we just want to return oh
now we'll just return component day
so that visitor takes care of that all
right so let's make a couple more of
these let's make a component B component
C you know you want to make as many as
you need
or whatever you need so we'll just uh
change all these to B and let's do the C
as well and Overkill at this point but
this time we're just gonna need to click
find and replace uh we gotta make sure
we get these functions right yeah make
sure we're calling the right visit Okay
so we've got all that now we just need
some visitors uh that Implement these
functions and as you might imagine we're
going to make a class for each one so
we're gonna make uh let's see virtual
ones called visitor other ones don't
really have a name I don't know we'll
just call it visitor a these are the
real ones ones you can actually
instantiate
and basically we just want to have some
special functionality for any of these
actually I don't want to call these a b
and c because these visitors could be
applied to any of the components they
just they basically want to do special
functionality based on what this visitor
is for so maybe we'd have like uh trying
to think of something I don't know
you're gonna have to use your
imagination I'm not really coming up
with anything but essentially these
would do different they would do
different things as they visit and have
some special functionality I guess for
now I'm just going to give them numbers
yeah set of letters that way they're not
you can they're not naturally Associated
by lettering because people might think
oh a only works with a that's not the
case they all interchange would be the
point so now we just got to implement
all these functions uh here and
determine what we're doing with them so
if they call these with
oh hold on we've made a little error
here gotta actually give these different
names ABC there we go okay so now the
visitor can either visit a b or c and we
need to give it some kind of function
definition we might just return for now
but uh now let's do a quick see out all
right let's make them log and we're not
using iostream at all until we get to
here so I'm actually going to put the
include i o stream right here which I
know seems awkward but uh sometimes when
you're doing header only stuff this is
how you want to do it just uh kind of
the fact of the header only method here
because this is all getting built into
the main so you want to you care about
the order of things a lot more and
you're doing it like this but disregard
that overall because that's kind of a
side point just about
the way I'm doing this all right so
let's use C out here and basically we
want to go well let's say this variable
comp and then we call its method except
we're going to call specifically
component a method here
so that's the one we're passed in that's
the one we have access to and then we
can say well we'll put like a visit in
here let's go visit it and then it'll
say whatever one it is and then we can
say from a visitor one cool
and we can basically do the same thing
for all of these except uh propagate it
down all the right function and this
will be B and this will be C so you can
make as many visitors to do as many
special things as you want for example
we'll make a second one let's call this
visitor to and we'll do some replacing
and uh there we go visitor to looks good
visitor one looks good and you can
imagine we could add a third if we
wanted and it'd be uh it'd be fine but
now let's go back over to our client
code and already include a visitor so we
can start working up an example and
typically when you're doing this you may
have like a big array of things and
you'll see kind of the point is
um as we add functionality with visitors
we don't have to edit the components
anymore the only thing we had to do was
just one time put this accept method in
and then we can have all kinds of
different visitors that do special
things publicly and if you want them to
have private access in any of these you
have to do some kind of friend thing
that's a whole other Avenue all right
let's let's do some examples all right
let's go over to our main
and let's let's see how we gonna do this
I guess we could use just like a vector
or an array Let's do an array I want to
go off another example I saw that I kind
of like this uh Vector it's going to be
an array of what components it's going
to be an array of components oh I copied
everything then
and we can say components
now what's this confused about I don't
think it knows what array is I think we
gotta include a gray here yeah that's it
all right now it should be a little
happier this was an array we also have
to declare how many let's just say let's
just say three there we go okay now
we're using the array syntax correctly
so three component pointers this is
essentially the same as doing it the old
way of making a raise but just uh yeah
well that's fine so let's instantiate
these I guess we could use uh
substantiation via this method new
component a
new component B new component C I'll use
the syntax too often because it always
feels awkward to me but we'll go ahead
and do it I always want to do something
like don't you gotta just gotta do this
well you can do it either way you're
just fine it understands what you mean
Okay so we've got three components
and now we need some some visitors so
let's make some visitors so let's make
visitor one and let's make visitor two
as V2 I don't necessarily need to make
them first but uh those are the ones we
have so we're making them quickly and
now what we can do is we can go over all
these components and run either visitor
on this so you might have a function for
this that takes in this array
specifically
um by reference or something
but you could also just go and just
right to the for Loop and just say const
uh component and components
spell this right there we go and then
you might run something like well we
just want to call accept on all of them
and we want to call it on I don't know
let's say V1 the first time now what's
wrong with this why doesn't it like this
let's have a quick look at visitor we're
at our component we want's a pointer all
right no problem so we could do this two
ways we could either just do it like
this we can just make these pointers
there's also ways to you know we could
put a reference symbol on there and it
would figure it out too but uh let's do
this
there we go now it just knows what they
are so we can do that first and then we
can go and we can do it again this time
putting visitor two on it and let's just
go ahead and see what that looks like so
I'm going to switch this over to visitor
make sure c-make's ready to go looks
like it is all right let's just hit play
we got a warning let's check out what we
got looks like it just doesn't
understand what a string is so let's go
over to visitor and find where we first
use string uh looks like it's on these
components so let's just include string
before that
and hit play again must have one more
error somewhere here and it says
component a does not take zero o yes we
have to pass it the plus so you do that
with this keyword it won't say const
pointer to the class of the component
and well we've got the class we're
inside of it we just need a conspointer
and this is a const pointer so we need
to put that in all of them and then hit
play and there we go we can see we
visited a b and c from one and two and
that's essentially the whole pattern
and of course we'd want to clean this up
and delete all the stuff so we'd
probably do this one more time and say
delete comp so it's going to delete and
we are uh exiting the program so this
doesn't actually matter but it's going
to clear at the end of main but if
you're deep inside your program
somewhere it doesn't necessarily clear
we can also do the same one delete V1
same for these
but it's good practice to do such a
thing and we return zero all right I
think that's pretty much it I don't
think there's a whole lot else to it
just study that example carefully it's
it's going to be the same in general
always uh with the visitor there might
be a few different hacky ways of doing
it I was kind of playing around with uh
before but I thought this is obviously
the superior version so this is the one
I'm going to show you all right well I
appreciate you guys
um doing your thing watching the video
and uh liking the video and all that
stuff if you want to help me keep making
these be sure to either uh you know do
all that good stuff or if you're if
you've got some serious Financial
Freedom and Danielle just want to help
out or you know whatever your budget is
I don't know I don't want to tell other
people what to do but you can also join
as a member or join on patreon and uh I
also listed your guys's feedback about
what you want to see next and uh stuff
like that a whole lot and also if you
sign up on one of the higher tiers I'm
happy to help you with some code if you
want to show me what you're working on
or anything like that so if you're
looking for a little of that we can do
that here as well just check those out
hit the hit the channel link
um and it's all on the about section of
the channel alrighty guys peace out see
you in the next episode happy coding